ESPN NBA insider Ramona Shelburne how
are you Ramona I'm just hanging in here
just taken in the draft best I can how
you been
I'm good good so I actually always like
to work on my birthday I know
everybody's like you know why are you
working today go home and I think it's
great because when you work especially
in our field everyone wishes you a happy
birthday and it's like a much bigger
deal where it's like if I'm at home yeah
I might go out to dinner with my husband
or like you know get a call from some
friends but like no you know it's mostly
just me in the Facebook messages right
no I'm like so it's better yeah and
there is no I in Ramona or Shelburne
it's amazing you know you're a team
player team player like that
so let me ask you about last night's
draft and what it means with the Hawks
acquiring the fourth overall selection
from the pelicans by way of the Lakers
does that mean does that mean that
that's officially a third team in and
that is beneficial for the Lakers being
able to push the trade into July does it
does that trigger something positive for
the Lakers so kind of like this you have
initial deal construction and then when
you modify that deal construction
everybody just has to be on board with
it everybody just has to say yet you're
we're okay with that but with for New
Orleans it's not exactly that way
because yeah they're getting the four
pick but it's sort of their asset to do
what they want with whereas IQ they're
not necessarily adding players or
anything to it it's just they're their
assets do anything with it so I guess
theoretically the Lakers would have to
agree to you know let the Orleans trade
the perfect but I don't I don't I
obviously don't know that's very
specific answer but I I think it doesn't
trigger anything I think that there is
always an understanding New Orleans but
would likely to move that kick which is
why you know the that's the whole point
of them doing the trade right they were
adamant they had to get the number four
pick and I honestly don't I don't think
New Orleans is done dealing I think
they're you know they won't even talked
about this last night on draft broadcast
like there
made a very specific set of things that
they were looking for in return for
Anthony Davidson one-on-ones a veteran
player too
to come to play with that team alongside
with you holiday and and their kids but
say yeah so let's figure that veteran
player is whether that comes by a salary
cap space that they now have or if they
have another trade network so then when
will we know if this trades official we
get a press release from El Segundo is
that the way I think I mean I really
can't we're in the moratorium now so you
know it's so I think that's it that's
the win it all so then how does this
then a hamper palinka grocery shopping
on July 1st oh it doesn't hamper it you
can because you can't cause any of those
technicalities it's the moratorium of
fights all this all the business in the
league and college I think so everything
is just a verbal agreement until July
thing you can't sign anything or
announce anything that's why with free
agent signings like teams will never
confirm them on the record you sort have
to get the agents to confirm them and
most of the time they don't even want to
go on the record because theoretically
and supporting the league's business
like you can't do anything till I say
right none of us really understood that
rule and implications of that rule
itself II Andre Jordan a few years ago
you remember that of course of course I
remember that that's where that's where
everybody learned like oh that's why the
moratorium is important okay like the
andre gave a verbal agreement and then
went back on that verbal agreement and
changed everything up and so I don't do
anything like that happening now but
there is there's there's all sorts of
reasons why there's moratorium there a
lot of it has to do with financial
accounting they need the league needs
time to reconcile books etc but it's the
reality is those days matter for how
much salary cap space the Lakers the
pelicans and any other team involved in
this trade is going to have and there
may even be another quemic is added if
the Lakers decide it's beneficial to
create even more salary cap space
through a fourth key so that that's the
hope you know obviously Ramona Shelburne
here in the rich doesn't show you know I
don't
we're not having this conversation
because we want to get into minutiae of
the NBA business but it's because the
the question of did Rob polenka strike
this deal under the best possible terms
for the Lakers to be able to add that
crucial extra piece or I have enough
room under the cap to create if best he
can his own Raptors type of supporting
cast for the two studs that he has and
Kuzma as well Ramona so you know you get
the latest discussion about this is
different than what we heard a few days
ago right a lot of it is because you
know a lot of people around the league
weigh in and sometimes it's the order in
which stories appear and so I think the
ways this happened was you know Bobby
marks and Load sort of figured out that
wow this they don't actually have room
for a third star based on the July 6
closing date and their reporting was
that the understanding was this was
going to close July 6 because the
pelicans would want what was the
opportunity to trade for peg or any
player in that and I'll tell you why
that's important okay whoever in the
fourth pick is turned out to be andre
hunter whether it's the pelicans or some
other team there know what i got to play
it some early great in no necessarily
want them to skip all summer league and
wait till July 30th they don't even get
to announce their draft pick that's
weird
or bring them into the system to tell
the deal closes we saw similar thing
like this in 2014 when Andrew Wiggins
became part of a trade to cleats from
Cleveland to Minnesota for Kevin Love
and I remember being in the gym there
where when LeBron committed and Wiggins
was getting ready to plays for a summer
league game with the Cavs
and it was a little awkward okay because
everybody kind of had this understanding
then he was probably not staying and
Kevin Love was going to be in this trade
but they did agree to postpone that
trade and they couldn't even talk about
that trade for another month until we
can decide to contract and from what I
understand Wiggins and his
representatives to get an insurance
policy on him because he plays summer
league with the cab
but it happened it's not the singing
that he was expected to go to so I was I
was very awkward so that's even more of
a stretch than this because that was
July 9 that was after the draft after
free agency the started some early this
is this is B this trade was done before
the draft but he's too hard to hold
everybody business up that long and I
don't think there was ever really a
chance for the Lakers to push that to
the July 30th date but the real issue
rich is where how do they did they ask
did they try you know we all have our
own reporting on that and I think it's
it's safe to say it wasn't a priority
for the Lakers and those discussions now
was it not a priority because they
realized New Orleans was likely to give
it to them there's folks who say that
okay
we're there people who didn't who didn't
make it a priority because they didn't
understand the full implications I think
that was the initial speculation on this
but my reporting on this is that they
the Lakers just wanted to get the deal
done and we're gonna hold it up over
something like this
yeah I mean Davis in here they had to
get him in before July 1 when they do
have to bring somebody in regardless of
how much you get for more nine more
million I mean we all know Ramona
certainly the two of us living here in
Los Angeles the concept of there being a
dumpster fire down the street from my
Studios here was the main main hindrance
one would think and also the concept of
whiffing on all free agents or anthony
davis was not a tenable it's it's not
even possible
they have anthony davis here beyond
eventually even LeBrons contract so it's
amazing a lot of the the hate and a lot
of the speculation that you're hearing
and so the question is is what what is
the lakers next move to the best of your
knowledge
once July first hits quality players and
it doesn't necessarily agency by the way
right Ukraine players into cap space so
that's another way you could replenish
your draft asset but you gave up in the
field but my understanding is unless
they're you who may need to have players
that are worth going through all the
gymnastics they would have to get
through they would have to go through to
get the de max cap space and even that
is the only thing quite get all the way
there it's really close so let's know
the top tier of free agency that's that
would be worth it to do all that and
it's not then you just add depth you
know you don't you don't do to all the
giant science is gymnastics for the
second tier or the third tier of free
agent Ramona Shelburne couple more
minutes left with her here on the Rich
Eisen show and now there's Kauai who
went to a Blue Jays game last night
created a whole hullabaloo because he's
there then we hear were are you know
rumor that he's shopping for boxes at a
Home Depot loge and and and reporting
from from the world wide leader being
that he's willing to go on a like an
Eastern Conference tour free agency tour
Ramona what do you make heads or tails
out of all of us information yeah he I
don't know what its title is what do you
I don't want to call him distant uncle
could be a lot more than example he's a
managers advisor very very important in
this process
his uncle lives in New Jersey so I think
there's the explanation for why he would
think about leading with the Knicks or
the Sixers or the Nets as well just
talking about last night I've heard that
as well so I can confirm all that but it
um that would be the reasoning behind
that or that and that's all I'll say
that that's my interpretation of the
reason be sure can be for Constantine
okay and I still still feels like this
comes down and do you stay in Toronto or
do you go to the Clippers or okay let's
it let's throw the Lakers in there
because it's LA but I think we're mostly
talking about the Clippers just feels
like it's that decision but look you
never know what happens when you get the
door
look if they you get a meeting get a
meeting really go back to Kevin Durant
when he seems an enhancer huh the team
that he was really impressed with but no
one ever thought I had a chance with
Boston River
Tom Brady showed up at the pitch meeting
and he was really impressed with that
Enoch went there you know first you got
to get a meeting and anyone who tells
you they know what Kauai is gonna do is
is going way too far out of the lynn
because i would say of all the free
agencies i have covered what Kawhi
Leonard thinks and what really comes
just from him not from anybody else is
about the hardest to determine as I've
experienced and is saying something but
it's also not surprising based on how
hard it is to get to know the guy anyway
and then based on on your reporting and
then the talking that you're here you're
hearing the the one free agency rumor
that you think is most likely to happen
in a couple Sundays from now Ramona of
Shelburne I do put a lot of stock in the
Kairi in the net I feel like there's a
lot there's a lot there but so I guess
that would be the one but it's changed
in the NBA over the last two three weeks
believable looking just just just a
couple weeks ago klay Thompson had an
ACL attack Kevin Rabbit is usually
Anthony Davis was still a pelican I mean
it it's amazing how much the league has
changed just in two or three weeks and
you know go back to February when we
were talking about Boston may be
training for Anthony Davis they couldn't
do it because it couldn't have Kyrie and
Anthony Davis on both on back field and
now it looks like they get both of them
Wow it's crazy right and if and if Kyrie
goes to the nets and somebody last one
for you somebody that's around these
parts and locked in on these parts as
long as you have how crazy would it be
if DeAngelo Russell wins back with the
Lakers how crazy would that be I mean I
went to the Mavs and was excited
instrument drinking tequila shots with
more cubed and then days later he
and it helps like barricaded in like I
mean I've seen a lot of Miss leaks and
nothing's crazy to me
Ramona thanks to the call thanks for
Doug you know hopefully you didn't get
stuck in traffic driving around here in
Lausanne tastic my mother Shelburne with
traffic and weather together here on the
Rich Eisen show thanks to the call
Ramona will chat soon you get that's
Ramona Shelburne here on the rich I've
at Ramona Shelburne here on the show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app